et là je bosse dur à cause de
l'épidémie pour 10 devant le britannique
reprenait face à l'euro il est vrai bien
mais il n'y a personne si jérémy cadot
vente à celle il faut les récupérer je
sais pas lu la bible et ça fait déjà
connu le plein bon voila tu as pensé à
nous téléphoner il a passé
et chez ses parents il est orphelin de
suite en cliquant vous savez tout ça on
observe une écoute l'institut goethe
accompagne bien fini pour nous
accompagne mais aussi pourquoi en
général enfin chez d autres c'est pour
savoir s'il est pas mort ok c'est décidé
on ira tous au revoir à plus quoi je
crois que da
n'est ce pas
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur on y désagréger on va
prendre de ses nouvelles et plus large
si chez moi le corps
on s'en fiche dégagé
excusez moi monsieur mais sur notre
statut de twitter et la réglementation
en vigueur dès le matin
parmi les cas la responsabilité de
généraux sécu ou pas mais si elle
m'accuse de bénéficier de certaines
aides financières les intimes
[Musique]
bazin il était avec nous totalement
hors éléments de voulez quoi depuis
quand jerry meehan famille mais bien sûr
qu'il a des amis
et son matelot
et que dire du style
las et ça vous inquiète pas plus que ça
sans nouvelles de lui sans moyen de
communication
oui j'aime bien ce sac c'est moi qui lui
ai offert parce qu'il était dit non ce
téléphone c'est moi qu'il faut faire
pareil alors n'est pas bien que je
m'occupe à lui lance si vous êtes si mal
si gentil va trouver le et comme je le
trouvais qu'il rafini faire la gueule
monde entier des liens
je fais toi
selon des études récentes de nombreux
fugueurs laissera concernant deux
explications
note particulière
j'étais bon
mon exposé
il avait trouvé un carnet qui indiquait
la passion de gérer nous pour les
sentiers dans notre île et tout
particulièrement celui de la rochelle
alors ils se mirent en route sous
l'impulsion de kendra mais non sans
difficultés
qu'est-ce que je fais là tout ça pour
mon exposé en la que je connais à peine
c'est trop dur j'arrive plus à réfléchir
il pouvait pas aller avoue campana
jeremy
oui on va tous se moquent les 8-11
mais pourquoi aujourd'hui ex'im a pu
embarquer
[Musique]
oas acquis ce mardi ou s'appeler
l'abuseur de maillard c'est un oiseau
qui vole trop la ferraille d'âge
non pas
les plus courageux allèrent jusqu'au
point de vue de la recherche cependant
ils ne trouvèrent pas jérémy mais des
indices qu'il avait laissées à leur
attention
bilou à la rivière quelle vie
allongement à cilaos
voilà on a monté de sabou rien alors
qu'on doit redescendre
malgré les protestations de juniors il
redescend dire le sentier et se mirent
en route vers la rivière sanofi
[Musique]
ou longer les berges de la rivière à
traverser plusieurs formules fini par
trouver encore
[Musique]
aller plus loin pour voir qu'à la
pression
nous tous
[Musique]
il va revenir à la vie
abaque et voilà que toi on a fait le
tour des listes hawn exagérons rien
juste une petite partie touché 1 2 qui
contient un peu plus au nord
[Musique]
je crois que tu l'as vu comme ça en plus
tant la pression créatrice de choses que
steve gestion en place regarde piqué ne
pense plus à la performance bras et
krishna sont vus avec vous à la montagne
et à la rivière sedona lâcher son livre
pour voir et sentir les choses ce film
c'est une fois qu'on peut refuser
mais ici la nature à l'antenne
le protocole est ce qu'ils apprennent
tout ce à quoi les impressions ici oui
mais je connais prix mais entre nous
[Musique]
grâce à l'école
comment ça
ces cas n'ont jamais touché
et c'est une carte de transport quelle
est la technique et haut-parleurs de
ménage avec tout ce qu'il fait est
arrêtée ce n'est sur la portée des comme
ça tout au collège alors
tiré attendant on retrouvera
cette journée maintenant
alors ils profitèrent de la joie sans
savoir toutefois si j'ai le miria maths
au collège quelques jours plus tard
jérémy décidé de revenir au collège
il voulait continuer ses études est
devenu guide de nantes il avait compris
que le meilleur moyen de vivre sa
passion était de la partager